I've mentioned before that there is a
second so-called steel dossier
Christopher steel of course being the
author of the Trump Russia dossier that
was the subject of extensive controversy
and now connects to multiple
investigations by the FBI special
counsel a special prosecutor by the US
House by the US Senate into possible
crimes committed by the Trump
administration the lesser known second
dossier is very interesting and there's
a really good piece in The New Yorker
that I read yesterday which talks about
the second dossier and points out that
more than likely Christopher Steele
discussed both of his memos dossier one
and dossier two I guess is what we're
calling them with special prosecutor
Robert molars investigators and there is
just a gigantic bombshell hidden in
plain sight in that second dossier as
well as in The New Yorker article and as
what it asserts is that as far as
Christopher Steele's research showed the
Kremlin intervened to block Donald Trump
from choosing Mitt Romney as Secretary
of State the reason that Russia
allegedly kiboshed Romney as Secretary
of State is that they wanted someone who
would lift Ukraine related sanctions and
it was pretty clear that Mitt Romney
wasn't gonna be the guy to do that and
of course hindsight is 20/20 we need
more information this is only the
beginning
but circumstantially this makes a lot of
sense to me as I thought back yesterday
about what happened between Trump and
Romney you'll remember that Romney was
invited during the transition period
between the November election and Trump
assuming the presidency in January of
2017 Romney was invited to meet with
Trump at his New Jersey Golf Club he was
invited to dinner with Trump where they
famously had turtle soup it really did
seem like Trump was going in the
direction of Mitt Romney as Secretary of
State and then suddenly Romney was out
of the running and at the time we
wondered what is this a power trip by
Trump is this Trump being so vindictive
that he wanted to make Mitt Romney come
out and grovel and may
we apologized for the things he said
about Trump during the campaign and more
or less begged for the job and then give
it to somebody else and personality-wise
at the time it fit Trump right and then
we never really learned more about it
but maybe at least based on this latest
information from the second steel
dossier maybe Trump genuinely plan to
hire Mitt Romney as Secretary of State
and didn't because Russia intervened and
think about who Trump ultimately did
select Rex Tillerson Rex Tillerson was
specifically known by Russians he was
known to be Russia friendly he was once
given a medal for being a friend of
Russia by Vladimir Putin we need to
learn more but circumstantially there's
kind of no better explanation for what
we saw publicly which is that Russia
said no to Romney and Trump ended up
going with the Russia friendly guy which
was Rex Tillerson now the White House
was asked about this they said oh no
Mitt Romney was never really our first
choice okay really hard to ignore the
big picture here which is Trump ended up
choosing the Russia friend who got a
medal from Putin over the guy who
clearly was not going to ease the Russia
sanctions and if your response is going
to be David fine Tillerson on paper is
more Russia friendly than Romney but
what his Tillerson State Department
actually done well he's eliminated the
office of the coordinator for sanctions
policy at the State Department for one
which would have been in charge of
implementing the sanctions that still to
this day have not been implemented we
just learned that Rex Tillerson State
Department has not spent any of the
money any of the hundred and twenty
million dollars that's been earmarked
dating back to 2016 for future elections
and stopping Russian meddling still
hasn't spent any of that so
circumstantially there is a lot here yes
but David Trump did just endorse Mitt
Romney to become me the next US senator
from Utah yeah so I don't think that's
going to convince anyone of anything now
that's just one vote in the Senate out
of a hundred it's not nearly as powerful
as the Secretary of State no doubt it is
something it's something but in the
grand scheme of things and particularly
in retrospect Russia also wouldn't have
as much
of an interest in trying to prevent
senator romney it appears at least
circumstantially that they'd have a
pretty significant interest in
preventing Secretary of State Romney
today's program is made possible in part
by futur vitur is a social forecasting
game where you compete with other
players to predict the future and it's
built on the principles of what's called
a prediction market a scientifically
proven way of using the wisdom of the
crowd to create more accurate
predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between you can check
out my predictions and follow me to get
updates on my profile which is linked to
in the description if you're watching
this on youtube the tour is a great tool
to find out more about the world improve
your forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecast it's free and it's available on
both Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers and that's f you t you you are
calm